[Music]
how far is oxford to blame for britain's
problems financial times journalist
simon cooper's new book chums looks at
how graduates from the university have
come to rule our country
toby young in his column for the
spectator this week doesn't quite agree
to debate the topic simon and toby join
spectator tv
simon cooper and toby young welcome to
spectator tv now simon could you start
by outlining your new book's thesis
it's about how oxford is so dominant in
the uk politically and has been since
the war i mean 11 of the 15 post-war
prime ministers went to oxford
and you know these are people from a
whole range of different political views
so we're talking thatcher harold wilson
tony blair david cameron boris johnson
really the whole
left to right of british power
and the book then focuses on the sort of
period 1983 1993
where again the people who will go on to
lead labor including kierstarma balls or
the milibands are there the people
around david cameron who will then lead
the remain campaign on their chiefly
cameron and osborne and then the people
i spend most time talking about are kind
of small minority
within the wider remain let's say oxford
the people who will go on to lead the
brexit campaign
and now rule the country so
boris johnson michael gove jacob
rees-mogg so it's not that oxford is a
hotbed of brexit because brexiteers are
always a minority they have but these
are the people who sort of won the
competition in our time so it's about
oxford it's about the current ruling
class
and the grip of oxford on on uk power
but you do draw a causal link there
don't you because as you say brexiteers
are a minority but you draw a causal
link between the culture of oxford and
what it encourages and how these as you
call them chums came to bring about
brexit and rule the country
i don't think there's a strong causal
link between oxford and brexit i think
there's a strong causal link between
oxford and power and there has been in
every generation
and so you know if you look at harold
macmillan in some ways he is a proto
boris johnson has a very very similar
path
into oxford and then their parts
separate because of history because i
mean mcmillan's second year i think
world war one breaks out and he leaves
forever but i think that
this group of people who i'm discussing
who are important because they they made
this huge change in the uk of brexit and
now they rule
they decided to use that power
for brexit
and i don't think that's an
inevitability of oxford at all
okay all right um toby
in your column for the magazine this
week you write that simon's book
contains incitements to class war topped
with a bit of walkery pokery i guess you
don't agree then
well um i should start by saying cindy
that um i very much enjoyed simon's book
um it's a very entertaining read i
devoured it in one sitting
it's full of amusing anecdotes um about
that period um and i think some of the
um
stuff um documenting what went on behind
the scenes at the oxford union and
elsewhere um struck me as spot on and
very well reported um so um you know i i
want to caveat everything i'm about to
say by by stressing you know what an
enjoyable entertaining read this book is
i mean particularly for me because i was
someone who was you know at oxford in
that period but i'm sure it'll be of
interest more widely um but um i do have
some reservations about um simon's um
hypothesis i mean he was i think being
slightly um cagey there
my reading of the book uh is that you
were very much trying to attribute um
the brexit project in particular um to
um a sort of uh group of tory toffs who
were typical of oxford and typical of
oxford
in this period and there is this sort of
marxist analysis that it was an
expression of class interest that really
it was about this group of toffs who
thought they were born to rule slightly
cross about the fact that westminster's
delegated or transferred some of its
powers to brussels and wanted to
repatriate those powers so they could
then march into westminster and claim
their birthright to sort of masters of
the political universe and i think that
i mean there may be a sort of kernel a
grain of truth there but i think that um
the problem with it is sort of twofold
first of all um uh uh just superficially
lots of the people who um led the brexit
project from that generation of oxonians
like michael gove and boris johnson even
jacob rees-mogg um are not exactly to
the man are born they're not sort of
conventionally posh particularly michael
gove one of the architects of the whole
campaign so i think there's there's a
slight there's a slight in the act
actually the people who campaign for
remain from that oxford generation david
cameron um rory stewart um george
osborne jeremy hunts uh nick bowles hugo
dixon we're actually a lot posher than
the people um who who were on the other
side so trying to link it to you know a
sort of fading ruling class trying to
kind of reassert its dominance and
reclaim its birthright that that struck
me as a little bit simplistic and also
at odds with one of the kind of
points the book makes which is that
politics in britain big political policy
debates aren't discussed with the
seriousness that they should be and this
feels a bit like a kind of slightly low
blow and ad hominem attack on the kind
of architects of brexit not the kind of
serious point i thought
simon wants us to kind of bring up when
discussing a big policy issue but i
think that the fundamental flaw with
this hypothesis and which i write about
in my spectator column this week is that
actually um remaining in the eu was
plainly in my view anyway um uh uh more
in the interests of britain's you know
ruling class than coming out of the eu
and that pattern was um you know that
was reflected in the pattern of votes on
you know june 23rd in 2016. it was a
genuine coalition between you know this
elite of oxford tori tops as he calls
them and you know vast swathes of
ordinary people across the country
whereas romain wasn't able to put that
coalition together i think in part
because remaining in the eu was
identified with a particular class a
kind of class of globalists um anywheres
i think because um david goodhart calls
them and and and that was really uh
why they lost so i think he sort of
fundamentally misunderstood brexit and
trying to kind of trace it to this group
of kind of um uh uh sort of cynical
non-serious kind of tory toffs at oxford
i think it's a little bit simplistic
simon
i would take issue with some of the
things that toby said there i mean this
is not a book that tries to explain why
17 million people voted for brexit they
had many reasons
i'm not suggesting that boris johnson
manipulated all these people obviously
there were attempts to manipulate but
that is that is what politics does
so the reasons why people voted for
brexit i think have been discussed in
other books what i look at here is the
people who led
um the brexit push
without whom it couldn't have worked i
mean if you just had nigel farage as the
leader of vote leave the only person
saying we must do this and you get like
the 1975 referendum it becomes against
fight for the fringe with somebody who's
not seen as a responsible leader it
wouldn't have happened so you needed
people like johnson and government
so i look at those people who then after
they win the referendum they jettison
farage and they become power now i don't
call them in the book a ruling class i
call it a ruling cast i mean that's a
subtitle because i don't think and i say
i don't think that pursuing kind of
narrow economic interests in this
marxist way that you accuse me of i
don't think they thought
our class needs brexit to protect it
economic interests which would be a
marxist analysis or anything else at all
i think it's a much more aesthetic
choice it's about um
attachment to british tradition and also
as i say in the book the idea that we
are the people who from the age of eight
are destined to go to westminster and
rule the country and we don't want
people from brussels uh pushing in on
that
and what they want to do with it with
their power in westminster is not so
much to protect uh some kind of vested
economic interests of their
caste which anyway is becoming less
economically significant as other people
gain
economic power in britain it's a much
more about we are the people who
traditionally rule the country and we
want to do something great with that
power like our like britain did in the
past and now britain's becoming this
sort of rather disappointing you know uh
offshoots of the european union we want
more than that
they're not typical of oxford i mean
oxford is a is a vast mix of mostly
upper class and then middle class people
like me and toby who
um probably were much larger in number
than the group of let's say boarding
school educated people
and that elite was divided yeah i mean
there were as you say there were people
like cameron and nick balls who thought
that um romaine was the way forward for
britain
and so it's not that um
all those people all come out for leave
at all
but i'm looking at the people who did
come out to leave and were important and
i tried to investigate the reasons why
they did
um
yeah i think that covers my retort
but simon why link it to oxford at all
then if oxford produces all sorts of
people and if these people that you're
talking about are a minority why talk
about uh what assets the oxford union
for example gives you in terms of
debating why talk about the tutorial
system and what skills that gives you
link it to boris johnson's for example
rhetorical skills you know because your
book is called chum's how a tiny cast of
oxford tories took over the uk and you
talk a little a lot about the
institutions of oxford as a university
and how that feeds into these people but
it's only going to be found anywhere are
they going to be found at cambridge and
other russell universities
if they're cast they could have come
from cambridge they could have come from
other universities or not from
university but the fact is
that the entire
ruling group of the different factions
in british politics in our time
with the exception of corbyn
farage he doesn't really have a party
they all come from oxford and so have 11
as they say 11 or 15 post-war prime
ministers so there's something very
interesting about oxford's grip on
british power that is worth
investigating it turned out that the
fact is i explained in this generation
that produced brexit that group of
people won but i mean if it had been
cameron
it would still i think would be worth
a book about oxford's grip on british
power
and then
the emphasis on rhetoric and the
tutorial system in the oxford union i
think
hugely affects the way that people who
end up in westminster um
rule and talk
sorry sydney you're interested
no no is um i was just going to ask
bring toby back in um
to be you out at oxford during this
period you were contemporaries of many
of the characters and people that simon
writes about is this accurate are are
these heady days of what simon describes
what do you remember
um some of it is yes um uh very
evocative and um brought it all back
um and as i say i don't think he he gets
the detail of um what oxford was like in
those days wrong um but i think his um
rather jaundiced view of oxford um and
um of the kind of cult of the gentleman
amateur the fact that you know people
who go into politics generally don't
have a science background or a maths
background and that that kind of
humanities bias that cult of the
gentleman amateur has contributed to
britain's problems and accounts for the
fact that we didn't have a very serious
grown-up debate about brexit and he also
i think links it to
boris's um government being at sixes and
sevens at the beginning of the pandemic
because you know they didn't have any
sort of medical or scientific expertise
and couldn't really cope with something
that required a mastery of that kind of
detail i think that's sort of a bit
unfair i mean it's a fairly familiar
critique of oxford and of the kind of
british educational elite and i think
it's um i think it's slightly unfair in
that i'm not sure that people like boris
and certainly not david cameron were as
unserious as simon presents them as
being i mean to be fair to simon he does
quote dan hannon in the book saying that
when he spoke to boris about whether
boris was going to campaign for leave or
remain in 2015 boris agonized over the
decision and that was i had a
conversation with boris at his 50th
birthday party before he'd fully made up
his mind and i think agonizing over the
decision is a good way to put it he did
really seem to be wrestling with it
weighing up the pros and cons
recognizing that neither option um you
know
that either option was sub-optimal um
and uh but it's it's it didn't it didn't
sort of suggest that he was just this
kind of you know dilatante treating it
as a kind of debating topic in the
oxford union he was taking it very
seriously and he takes it seriously
because i think at bottom he's a patriot
and i think most of the people who did
campaign for brexit however much you
might disagree with uh their point of
view i think they thought that it is in
the best interests of this country and
campaign for it in good faith i'll just
pick simon up on one particular point um
he he he he remarks frequently in the
book on the dominance of a kind of
handful of elite public schools um at
oxford you know their products are
wildly over-represented at oxford
compared to the products of the school
that simon and i went to turns out we
went to the same uh grammar slash
comprehensive in north london um that's
certainly true and i know i share i
share most people i think share simon's
misgivings about that um but um one
thing you overlook simon is that many of
the people you condemn as members of
this kind of superficial caste
of kind of you know um oxford union
hacks is that actually a a pretty
serious effort was made
under the coalition government and and
beyond to try and reform british
education to try and improve standards
in state schools to try and make sure
that oxford cambridge the russell group
more generally wasn't as dominated as it
is by products of a few elite schools
you know michael gove i think was very
serious about that dominic gobe was
involved in that project david cameron
supported
um gove and cared about that himself you
know if the if if in if your kind of
analysis which is that
this kind of cast of kind of toffs
wanting to kind of restore their
birthright and restore powers to
westminster so they could they could
then become masters of the universe and
it was all about perpetuating their own
privilege if that's correct then how do
you explain that they made this pretty
serious good faith effort to actually um
reduce
the influence of of their class and
people from their schools you know
it seems to me it's a bit one-sided you
don't really you're not really quite
fair to
um this group that you evidently don't
like very much and blame for many of
britain's problems
i mean there has been a push in recent
years in the last five years in
particular i would say to make oxbridge
in particular uh more
fair in admissions
and so there's been a huge rise since
about 2017 in the number of state school
people getting into oxbridge i think at
oxford now at 68 state school which in
the last year which is the highest ever
recorded i mean a lot of those people
come from the posh kinds of state
schools
they um so it state school covers a
variety of sins so if you from a leafy
grammar in buckinghamshire that's a
state school so oxford is totally not
there yet but things have got better
i agree that gov was serious about
making british education fairer
i would say the situation as it was when
toby and i went to university was just
totally unsustainable
i mean it's hard to think of a western
of a european country with that level of
unfairness in admissions in the 80s so
only about one in eight people were
going to university at all and if you
wanted to do classics which typically
meant that you come from a public school
you're trying to get into oxford in the
early 80s was two and three it really
was not that competitive
and just dozens and dozens of people
from public schools would come in so yes
oxford now if i were writing a book
about oxford in 2022 it would be
different
but the thing is that the elite is
produced 30 years earlier
that um
the people we see in power today come
from a past that i've tried to disinter
in the book just on lack of seriousness
i mean whether you're four against
brexit i didn't want to write a book
about brexit is bad brexit is good i'm
against brexit but i thought it would be
incredibly boring to write a book saying
brexit is a bad idea the whole product
nation has had that debate for six years
everyone's fed up with it nobody changed
their minds but whether you were four
against in the referendum there should
have been serious debates about the
customs union
about the irish border about a divorce
bill about the single market how does
that work you stay in the single market
but you leave the eu what are the
modalities of doing that that was not
discussed by either side and so that to
me the referendum
whichever side you're on was not serious
enough for the task japan
simon just very finally i wanted to uh
something that struck me about your book
at the near the end was solutions that
you talk about to to not make oxford
this kind of elite hotbed
and you say that perhaps oxford should
stop teaching undergraduates so i just
wondered all your thoughts about that
because in light of the conversation
that we've just been having about how
much more diverse is becoming you know
full disclosure i went to oxford i did
ppe at christchurch one of the most
infamous colleges there but i went to a
state school and i'm also an immigrant
who wasn't even born in this country you
had to learn english at the age of 10.
oxford for me was life-changing if you
stopped taking undergraduates you know
you'd be denying opportunities to not
people like the future boris johnson but
people like me so how do you describe
that
well somebody like you i mean here we
are three state school people who went
to oxford and um ended up lucky
but how do you as somebody like you
could have gone to another university
that would have been great you could
have gone to the university of london or
uh you could have gone to
reading or bristol you could have had an
excellent experience because you're a
motivated intelligent person then you
could have gone to oxford 22 under what
i propose and do graduate work what i'd
love to see and i say at the end of the
book is an oxbridge for all that we say
you know you're 35 years old you didn't
go to university first time around or um
you didn't have a good or sufficient
experience you are not from a class that
was directed towards oxbridge but you're
bright you're intellectual we're going
to take you and you can have a year at
oxford or three months or whatever it is
that
that works for you we have time for and
so we spread the undoubted excellence of
a lot of oxford to a much broader part
of the population than just this really
rather small group of middle class plus
upper class people that for most of
even today for most of the last few
hundred years it's been educated
so would you say not to end under
undergraduate teaching at oxford then
just spread the goodness a bit more
i i would i i just think it's
the grit the unfairness of the selection
essentially at age zero raid six to
oxford and therefore your ticket to the
establishment well not quite in my case
not in your case but um unusual
exception i'd be interested to see what
toby thinks
um well i i certainly think that um
uh you know more children from state
schools should be going to oxford and
cambridge and to elite universities more
generally and you know um i've i've
spent quite a lot of time over the past
um uh 10 or 12 years um trying to
try to help um in various ways um you
know setting up um co-founding for free
schools at a multi-academy trust and
doing our best to encourage all the
children at those schools to uh aim high
educationally um but um i mean my
experience of oxford i think in some
ways was um different um to simon's um
and um seemingly i had a kind of
slightly better experience than he did i
mean that may be wrong
i think that's wrong i had a really good
time i really enjoyed it i don't feel
better about it
i was going to say that um uh i um in
the group of people studying ppe at
brazenos um who came up in 1983 um there
were 10 of us i think and within that
group of 10 a huge range of um political
views from a kind of
monday club kind of tub thumper on one
at one end to a kind of libertarian
conservative at the other um and it it
whereas i went to harvard um a couple of
years after oxford and within the entire
harvard government department there was
nothing like that range of views it was
really just kind of people arguing about
different interpretations of liberalism
it was nozikian liberalism versus rawsi
and liberalism and that was really the
only debate and i like the fact that at
oxford there was this kind of huge range
of different opinions and it spoke of a
kind of pluralism a real intellectual
diversity accompanied by a good deal of
intellectual tolerance and real debates
about really important big issues and um
and i think it would be a shame to lose
that and replace it with something kind
of more technical more vocational i
wouldn't say technical vocational i mean
if you're 35 and you didn't go to
university you're very bright and you
want to study shakespeare great
but simon you can't have it both ways
either knoxville education is a good
that more people should be having or
it's bad and we shouldn't be giving it
to anyone
it's not either good or bad uh it can be
good and it can be bad i think that
there was a lot of kind of skating over
thin eyes winging it lazing around uh
also
education wasted on 18 year olds who
took their privilege for granted but it
also is not the highest one of the
highest ranking universities in the
world for nothing
and the intelligent people going
ranking is mostly about research and
oxford has the largest research budget
of any european university it has
amazing academics
now much more than in the 80s because in
the 80s a lot of them didn't even have
phds and published in the paper
um and it does it does some fantastic
research and i think that
the teaching it does
i would rather see spread
much more broadly to a much wider range
of talent
all right okay well i think we'll have
to leave it there simon cooper and toby
young thank you so much for joining
spectator tv
[Music]
you